hi
my name is yuri sundempotson and in this
presentation i will give
a few highlights of what's new and
what's coming
in pandas anno 2020 slides were created
together with tom oxbow
and will also be available for questions
we are both
maintainers of pandas a python package
providing one of the
fundamental building blocks for working
with tabular data
data frames in python
so one of the major milestones of this
year
is that we finally had a 1.0 release
in january of this year itself
this 1.0 was not a very special release
in terms of big new features for example
but mainly it was high time to finally
have
such a 1.0 release
[Music]
and even though we now have that release
there is still a lot of development
going on with lots of bug fixes
improvements and new features in the
latest latest releases and also we're
working on some beer experimental
changes
so way too many changes to
i'll talk about here so for this talk i
picked one new feature to highlight
which is a better integration with
number
after that i will explain uh two data
type related experimental
changes that are on the roadmap and that
you are working on
new string data type and work related to
missing data but first
a few slides with some other project
updates
so we have an active community
with a growing user base many people
are also contributing to pandas so for
example the
last year we had more than 50 regular
contributors
and we recently also expanded the core
team
it's very nice to see such a active
community
of course that also brings challenges
with keeping up with the changes and
pull requests and all the maintenance
works work
that is involved now
this year for the first time we had
some significant funding from the czi
open source
initiative and this way we were able to
compensate
a little bit of the maintenance work
involved in pandas
for example simon hawkins has been doing
the release management for the latest
releases
and he was be able he was able to do
that
on this grant we also use the grant
to fund some specific feature
development related to
string data and which is a topic i will
come back
to later in the presentation i also want
to mention
the new focus smart development grants
which helps
financing some specific projects
we also have a new logo uh it's actually
not news of this year but
from last year i thought still worth uh
mentioning
big thanks to mark garcia here to lead
this effort
and to indeed for sponsoring and work on
this
we also have been working on an improved
documentation team
and a new getting started guide
sponsored by new focus
we're very happy that other projects
also start
uh picking up the new things theme
the slide shows the jupiter hot docs
and jupiter book but for example
also numpy started using the team
recently so it's
great to see some collaboration on this
effort but
let's now go to the more interesting
part of this
uh presentation a few demos
in the first demo i want to showcase one
of the new features of panels 1.0
which is better integration with number
for moving
and goodbye operations
for the demo let's switch to a notebook
and so i will show here a
functionality related to moving window
operations which was added in 1.0
and later it was expanded to go by
operations in
1.1 release
but let's first show a small example of
such a rolling or moving window
operation
so i'm creating here a series
with some random data and
pandas provides the functionality to
compute a moving window or rolling
aggregation in this case i'm using
the mean function to calculate the
average
for each window of 10 rows
and it's actually quite fast for and
this million uh
points and those building functions
and they are implemented in pandas
in optimized uh way so
in general it's always advisable that
try to use one of those built-in
functions like
the mean in this case and that the
typical reductions
are implemented now
in some cases it might not be possible
to
put to express the operation you want
in one of those built-in functions
and in those cases
you can write your own function with
your custom logic
and apply this in the rolling
operation so a small example here i
define my
user defined function in this case i'm
just using
again the mean and to be able to compare
it to my example above
but of course in practice you should
only write your own
custom function if you have more
special logic in there
[Music]
but let's apply it
apply this rolling this user defined
function
in my rolling operation small note i'm
using
raw equals true here to ensure to pass
numpy arrays
to my function and not
and not pandas series objects
so you can see exactly the same
operation but and
much slower so seven seconds compared to
25 milliseconds so
that's the reason that in general you
should use
try to use those built-in functions as
they are much
faster than applying a custom function
but in cases where it's not possible
that's where
the new feature of using number comes
into the picture
so number is a just in time compiler for
python code
and especially well suited to speed up
numerical
algorithms and working with arrays of
data and computing
on that and pandas now provides a way to
use number
or and then to just in time compile
functions using number
in moving window or group by operations
and that can make
yeah applying this function much faster
first time you see it's not
it's it's already faster but not that
much faster
because the first time you do it there
is some overhead in
just in time compiling uh differentiate
the function
so it's mostly useful if you want to
apply the same
function multiple times so doing it
again here and you can see now it's
actually much faster and so we're coming
from seven
seconds down to um
yeah around 180 milliseconds
you can see it's still a bit slower than
the built-in sum
that originally was 25 milliseconds
but and for the cases where you need a
custom logic in the user defined
function
using the number engine can provide
a very nice speed up
so it was a first demo showing some new
features
now i would like to move to explaining
some of the
experimental changes we are doing in
panas
and the first topic here is about
working with string data and how we're
trying to improve
working with string data i will again
go to notebook notebook for
string data and to explain this let's
first take
a step back and look at the current
situation
for that i'm reading some
data titanic data sets i have a data
frame now
and you see different columns with
different data types and including
a few columns that have string data in
it for example here the name
column so we can inspect
the data types
[Music]
and if you're looking at that and you
see here
object type and um it's
yeah i think a typical case when
explaining to
new users how data types work in
that yeah this object d type that
typically means that you have
a string data so um
if you have string data you are sure
that you have an objective type
but it's not because you have an object
detect that it means that it are
stringed so it's not
guaranteed to be stringed it can also be
any other
python object or some error that
numbers ended up in an opticity type
column
so this gives yeah not very
good user experience um for this
and it's not a clear data type there is
no guarantee
so it's not a very nice user experience
and that's something that you are
trying to improve by
introducing a dedicated string
data type it's something that was added
to pandas
in the 1.1.0 release
um and to show this
let's convert the previous data frame
using a helper method to convert some
data types but just focusing on
string data from now to a new
data frame and let's again take a look
at the
data types you can see now we actually
have
string data it indicates here that we
have
a string data type
so already giving a
much clearer message about the data
types
of your data frame i can create such a
series
manually as well indicating here i want
a string data type
i can for example set some
data but in addition to it being
now an actual string data type it also
means that we can be
strict about it and unlike
objective type we can which can contain
anything
now it's only allowed to contain strings
so if i
want to put here some number in my
series
it will actually give an error because
you can't put a float in a string
data type
now under the hood it's still using
an object d type numpy array with python
strings
as before so the implementation
is very similar as but is now being used
with uh
for object d type but at least the
intent is already much
cleaner um and because we are using
those python objects for the individual
strings
it's um it's actually quite difficult to
write
optimus optimized and fast algorithms
working on those strings and to improve
on
this aspect as well so the aspect of
performance
we are looking into leveraging apache
arrow
to improve these aspects
so that brings me to a second part of
this notebook
[Music]
and to be clear this part is not yet
released it's not even
in a development version it's still
a work in progress in a pull request
on github
what is it about so it's using apache
arrow
and to give some backgrounds here apache
arrow is
the project that tries to define a
standard
cross-language memory representation for
tabular data
and in addition it also provides
libraries
in several languages
that implements this standard and also
it
provides functionality to work on such
data and that's what we will be
leveraging here under the hood impound
so we want to
use the memory representation and the
algorithms
of apache arrow under the hood
in pandas when you have string data
to show this i created some
some random data a bigger data set with
strings in it so there are some
random strings i extract this series and
i convert it
to the string data type that i just
explained
above so using the none by object array
approach after that um
i will now also create a version of this
series
using the arrow string data type
to be clear what you see here is not the
final
api how it will look like for the user
it's just
the the temporary development version
but you see that now my series here
still has string
data but it's now using apache arrow on
the dots
so what are the reasons that we want to
use apache arrow so
first reason is the
memory usage
so if you compare the memory usage of my
python strings versus the
arrow strings you can see that
the series with back by arrow memory
is using quite a bit less memory
the exact ratio between the two will
depend
on your on your data and typically if
you have
longer string data and the the
difference will be smaller
but so but the reason for this
difference is
that the um in the python series so in
the first case
uh each string is stored in a python
object
um which has some overheads uh while
in the arrow memory all the string data
are
stored in one contiguous array of
of characters and we then also store
in apache arrow stores and also the the
indices pointing at
where the individual strings start
by having this more efficient memory
representation
it's not only using less memory
but it's also more efficient to write
optimized algorithms
working on those data and let's
show some examples here
as well
the first example um
is uh converting to lowercase
uh so all converting all strings to
lowercase so you can see that
with the uh arrow version we get
a nice speed up for this kind of
operation um another example
just checking if something is equal
to a certain
value and also here you will see that
the arrow version is quite a bit
faster and final example
also uh contains uh
operation so it's a it's a match of
substring so um checking for each of
these strings
in the uh series whether the
a1 string is
somewhere present in as a substring of
the full
string and also here and you see a nice
speed up um and just
as a sanity check to ensure that i'm not
lying here but
the two versions actually return
the same result so you can check here
that indeed
they are giving the same result
so how does this work um
as i already explained the apache arrow
has an efficient memory representation
specifically for those variable size
strings
storing them all together so we can
write efficient algorithms
in pandas we can then use this under the
hood
in the example here it was still
explicit but
in the food in the future when it's
actually released we will ensure that
there is
an option to use it and then it's used
by default when creating
strings one thing to note is that
not everything will be more efficient
because it's stored in one
contiguous array operations where you
for example want to
modify one element somewhere in the
middle of your array
that's a example of an operation that
will be
less efficient with this version
as a final note for this notebook i want
to
thank the czi for funding this work
using the the the grant martin bredes
brothers was able to work on
some of the algorithms on the apache
arrow sides
and we have been with several people
working on the on the panda site
to integrate it into the internals of
the
string data type
[Music]
so that was about
ongoing work on the string data type
and again so the the actual string data
type so the first part that i showed
is already available in a released
version
the the fact that it can be backed by
apache arrow
that's work in progress
but so let's move to a second topic from
our
roadmap and that's about
missing data so we are working on
improving the experience around missing
values
in pandas and let's again first take
a look at the current situation for some
context opening my
third notebook so
for this i'm creating here a small dummy
data frame uh with columns of
using different data types so i have a
data frame with
some integer data before data boolean
stream and timestamps um
if i look at the data types
um there are a few things that you can
notice
um so first thing and something probably
most of you will be
aware of that if you have integer data
but also missing values that it gets
caused to
two float data types so you can't store
integer data with missing values
currently in pandas
that's for integer data but also for
boolean data it can
natively store missing data so here
for missing data for boolean data it
gets
cast to object t type
in addition to this variable support
across data types
you can also notice that there are
different
indicators for the missing data that is
being used so for those two columns you
see here
none so it stands for not a number and
it's a floating point
value for the boolean and string data
we're actually using non here but it
could also be
none and in the time some data
then there is yet another indicator
nat for time
um so and this is
a quite yeah um i would say
a bit of messy situation uh not all data
types support it
different indicators so that's uh the
reason
why we're trying to improve um this
situation therefore
we are working on new what we call
nullable d types and
the 1.0 release
of this year introduced a new
indicator and the pd.na missing value
indicator so to replace
np.nan and non or nat as a missing value
sentinel
and it also introduced a few data types
that are already
started using this so we have a nullable
interior boolean and stream
data type in 1.0 in the upcoming
pandas 1.2 release to also be supported
for
floating data
[Music]
let's again look at the
previous data frame but now converted to
the new data types so the convert d
types
method is a small helper method to
convert
the columns of the data frame to
same data but using the new
data types so if you look at this
column so the the first thing you can
notice here
that now um all of those columns are
using the same
indicator for having missing data
the timestamp column not yet so that's
something we still have to do
uh in the future but for those columns
it's already this bd dot name
so that's a new
uh a new object that was introduced in
panels 1.0
and so it's used as the
indicator for uh missing data
it stands for not available it's the
same terminology as
i used in r for example and it's similar
to the null
from sql
[Music]
then if you look at the data types of my
data frame here
you can now see that it's my
column with integers is now actually
indicating that it's using it's an
integer data type
the same for my boolean column it's now
indicated it are actually
rules and not and this object d type
um and it's also using the the string
data type so the
um the string data type that i
introduced in the previous notebook
is also using this pd.net as their
as its missing value indicator
one note here you will see here the uh
the n64 with the capital so
that's a bit uh a tricky uh thing but to
differentiate from the numpy id type
which doesn't support missing values for
integers
we are using here the form we take
capital
um so for those data types where
to otherwise overlap with a
d type
so in general those
new nullable d types if you have columns
for those d types
using pd dot n a it would work
similarly as before if you used
uh none for flow data or or with object
t type
so all the functions specific to
missing data will work as expected
with it so things like fill in a isn't a
not an a
drop in a those functions they will all
work with
those noble d types as well
there are however a few differences in
behavior
that are worth noting compared to
the the current behavior when using non
or
none as missing value indicator
so um to show that i'm creating two
small
serieses so one
using pdf and a and new nullable
interior data type
another the current default so which
the interiors gets caused to float data
[Music]
first when doing reductions
like taking the sum that's
still the same as before by default
there is there are skips but you can
always
indicate that you don't want to skip
and then it properly so that's something
that
is still working the same as it did
before
also for elementwise arithmetic
operations
again it's exactly the same as before
so missing values in
the inputs will get propagated to the
output
however when looking at comparison
operations
so equal or larger or
lesser than this kind of operations
there
it will also propagate
um if you ask for
my series whether it's equal to one
my second element was a missing value in
the
inputs and it will also be one in the
output because we don't know
whether this missing value was equal to
one or not
and since we don't know we keep it as a
missing value in the output
and that's different than the behavior
that you currently get when using
none as a missing value indicator there
all comparisons with none always uh so
none is never equal to
some other value or to itself
so you get here in this case a false
in addition for logical operations there
is also
some different behavior
for example for the end operation so if
you do
n a n true um
the result depends uh whether this what
the exact value of this n a is so we
don't know the result so
the n a here is propagated and we get an
a
as a result on the other hand if you do
the same between
or operation n a or true
regardless of the actual value of this n
a whether it's true or false
because we already have a true on the
right side of this operation
we know that the result will always be
true so
in this case we don't propagate and dna
will actually return true
um so that were a few examples of
uh behavior of this new na value
how does this work in practice um for
the
numeric ones we are using a masked array
approach
we're not using the the numpy
implementation of this but
our own but the concept is very similar
um so we have one array of actual data
in addition a separate array indicating
for each of the values which are missing
or not
it's experimental so meaning there's
still
a lot of work we need to expand it to
more data types
to ensure it's fully supported in full
of pandas
but at the end goal is certainly to
complete this work that
they can become the default
i have to repeat again this is
experimental
and so it's certainly not um recommended
to use this in
production code now that's it
we actually want that those and data
types become the default at some points
in pandas and thus the more people
trying it out
the faster we might get there so
any contribution whether it's in time uh
trying it out and providing feedback or
actually working on the code doing some
improvements
sponsoring is all very welcome
and to speed up the implementation
so that was the the last demo
uh for this talk um i hope that
i could show some of the ongoing
developments in pandas and some
change that i'm excited about myself
and as a final note i want to thank the
uh the pandas community for their
efforts
contributing in all kinds of ways to to
the pandas
project and because what i presented
here in this talk
is not my own work and but it's actually
work of the
of the full community
you